voici brian molko
[Musique]
brian molko placebo
brian molko de placebo vous êtes ici
pour votre nouvel album qui s'appelle
sleeping with ghosts
[Musique]
c'est quand même génial c'est quand même
génial cette émission parce que sur le
même plateau nous avons brillante dans
le cou de placebo et sacha distel
c'est fou alors sleeping with ghosts ça
veut dire dormir avec des fantômes mais
s'est consacré en fait à relation passée
con qu'un rien qu'un petit rien peut
faire revivre
vous dites on est hanté par les
relations qu'on a eu dans le passé en
froid que ce soit les les anciens amants
ou où la famille quand on fait l'amour
essayons bon on peut être ouais des fois
les défunts les fantômes de daman passé
reviennent tenter par un petit fait
l'amour avec quelqu'un d'autre ça c'est
enquiquinant se tire dans le pied ouais
ouais mais là gaye
je suis sûr que certaines fois il
apparaît alors c'est cette spiritualité
qu'on trouve dans votre dernier album
est pas et pas très étonnante parce que
vous avez été mystique à ces jeunes
autour de l'âge de 13 ans vous avez été
ce qu'on appelle un born again christian
c'est-à-dire un chrétien rené ouais j'ai
donné mon mon âme à christ à l'âge de 11
ans en fait ouais étrange chose à faire
mais je les fais quand même bien
l'époque vous aviez souvent voir un
prêtre un barbier avec lui ben c'était
le ministre de notre notre église ont
fait céder petit séminaire ensemble
moi je trouve ça quand j'y pense parce
que c'est un petit peu et presse que le
bien-être qui avait déjà subi texte un
petit peu un de quelque chose d'autant
plus lâché patients parce que les
religieux les prêtres
cg rien passé avec bien sûr non non non
non nous diriez sinon bien sûr merci ça
ferait une une bonne petite nouvelle ça
bat et oui c'est ce qu'on disait tout à
l'heure avec un à béatrice veut dire que
c'est important quand on est une femme
comme toujours je dis que j'ai jamais
été violée par mon père avant
alors tout ça s'est arrêté cette
spiritualité ce mysticisme vers l'âge de
14 ans quand vous avez découvert votre
sexualité et je dirais pas que la
spiritualité elle s'est arrêtée mais
la sphère d'amour avec la religion
organisée way we s'est arrêté ouais
quand je me suis rendu compte que qu'il
y avait des sentiments moins que demain
que mon prêtre ma mère et les gens de la
congrégation étaient contre et je
suppose que là c'était le début d'une
rébellion qui qui s'est enchaîné comme
une boule de neige - un petit peu qui
est voilà qui est ce qu'aujourd'hui les
dents et d'inde
jusqu'à jusqu'à presque maintenant j'ai
30 ans jusqu'à presque mais trentaine
est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes croyant
toujours je pense vraiment que si on
croit qu'ils à un acheteur life un
paradis un qu'on arrête de vivre que on
se dit que la vie c'est une répète pour
quelque chose d'autre
moi je trouve ça dommage la vie n'est
pas une répétition la vie c'est la pièce
de théâtre donc là effectivement après
ses expériences mystiques adolescente
vous vivez au luxembourg donc avec un
père qui est banquier américain
une mère qui est catholique écossaise
c'est un peu dur pour vous parce qu'en
plus ils refusent que vous vous
inscriviez aux cours d'art dramatique de
l'université brian et là vous vous
rebellez vous enfermer dans votre
chambre pour faire de la musique et il
n'y avait pas grand chose à faire au
luxembourg on avait des bons disquaires
alors ouais je me suis enfermé dans ma
chambre à coucher
j'apprenais la guitare et j'écoute la
musique loin comme un fou c'était
c'était ma façon de m'échapper et de
créer mon monde à moi et vous avez fait
votre premier album dont le titre est
assez significatif
ça s'appelle qui nagent en qu'est ce qui
veut dire l'angoissent adolescente et
l'or s'était inspirée par une discussion
vous avez eue avec votre mère qui vous
avait dit dès que tu sors du vagin tu
commences à mourir c'est une phrase qui
est resté avec moi c'est une phrase qui
mentent
ouais encore alors le disque que vous
sortez aujourd'hui
va un petit peu plus loin que les
précédents au niveau de l'entrée
spéciaux on a le sentiment que d'un seul
coup vous êtes arrêté un petit peu vous
avez un petit peu arrêter la rock'n roll
life
les pétards les sorties tout ça et vous
êtes un petit peu posé vous avez
réfléchi c'est quand on bouffe trop de
gâteau il y en a marre après après une
sens centaine ça comme ça mais quand
même un séjour si je dirais que c'est
plutôt c'est plutôt la qualité que la
quantité
ouais tels que le textile est en train
de devenir sage au bon sens du terme
toujours un petit coup mais j'essaye
ce que je vois
vim
axel alcoa
m
salut à faire honnêtement c'est jack
gold est fait comme ça d'être d'être
adulé ouais ça fait un drôle d'effet
ouais ouais c'est vrai c'est dur à vivre
ça 1
c'est étrange ouais c'est étrange c'est
pas nécessairement du rav ils pleurent
les peaux questions qu'un petit coin
qu'est ce que vous pensez de sable à
yann vous pensez que vous méritez pas ça
ou vous pensez que la musique que vous
faites mérite ça un jerry plutôt la
musique que je fais avec mes frères mais
mes frères en musique mais steve et
staff du groupe qui a plus de valeur que
moi en tant que que personnage
médiatique nanana truc comme ça parce
que c'est ça c'est transparent tout ça
et puis ça peut ça peut disparaître
comme ça me motive à merci
messieurs
à la batterie s'il vous plaît brian
molko j'ai beaucoup aimé ça serait bien
pour votre légende avoir une aventure
avec un mec un peu trouble comme c'est
un peu un peu bizarre mais qu'un peu
trop maquillée est ce que moi je lui
plais no way si brian molko
laurent brian molko utilise la carte de
bons clients que trois fois donc il
vient quand il veut ça la programmatrice
retiens tu peux venir quand tu veux
merci la dernière fois que tu es venu il
y avait sacha distel ce soir ya hervé
nord
vous avez un point commun tous les deux
c'est camille absolument vous avez plat
mais au moins c'est que comme hervé
vilard tu as été brian ami avec un
prêtre c'est vrai voilà vous avez fait
des petits séminaires ensemble à
l'époque signe enfin si non et puis
toile problème c'est qu'elle est
horizontale découverte la sexualité tu
as oublié les curés ouais les curés ne
veut pas ne m'ont pas oublié sa tête est
victime de gm était victime
moi je peux couper ses gestes j'ai
besoin de moi même d'accord de porto
dans la voiture bien sûr baron certes
mais en fait c'est peut-être cette
enfance proche de ce curé qui affecte
plus dernièrement tu as fait un disque
qui s'appelle sleeping with ghosts
c'est-à-dire dormir avec des fantômes
10e mistissini peut-être qui est revenu
mais j'ai toujours une caresse avec moi
j'ai toujours
moi je suis reconnaissante je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup
aidé avec avec les chrétiens aient des
métaphore biblique c'est quelque chose
de très très fort alors je suis effet
oui on peut faire une très belle chanson
il ya de très belles choses dans la
bible à chanter wayne est un habile il
ya plein d'inceste violent via parents
c'est mon gars ça aussi c'est
intéressant parce qu'ils sont allés
vraiment creusé au fond des choses c'est
que cette dernière fois brian molko
s'est très bien entendu que ces chats
distel et ce soir je pense que tu vas
très bien attendre le quart d'heure
bizarre c'est quand même une mission une
mission du choc des cultures
alors cet album sleeping with ghosts est
réédité avec dix reprises de grands
standards internationaux
il ya johnny et mari de robert palmer il
ya melody nelson de serge gainsbourg
gady cool de boney m tkm extraordinaire
de voir placebo qui joue du bonnet m et
puis aussi la réédition en français d'un
morceau qui s'appelle protective mois
dagong qui s'appelle protège moi en
français avec des paroles de virginie
despentes
alors depuis que vous êtes venu brian
dans cette émission est à peu près un an
j'ai lu un article une interview avec
etienne daho dans rolling stones et vous
vous énervez contre la télé réalité
vous dites que si une insulte à la pop
vous dites ça devrait pas s'appeler à la
recherche de la nouvelle star par
exemple ça devrait s'appeler à la
recherche du nouveau chanteur de karaoké
ses cliques et en profitent
ouais vraiment cessé d'accompagner le
téléphone c'est la maison disque
et puis c'est la compagnie de télé c'est
pas vraiment un séjour est et a toujours
été une histoire de pognon il ya
toujours eu un type qui étaient là
derrière pour ramasser le pognon claude
françois ou qui tu veux même si tu les
connais pas
ou lucienne boyer où ils ont passé le
magot d'abord et je sais c'est lederman
qui après des gens qui on ne fait pas ce
métier avec la télévision la télévision
n'est pas représentatif de notre métier
nous changer ce qu'il est en train de
bien c'est pas qu'on fait pas ce métier
des bisons il dit maintenant sélection
qui fait ce métier non c'est faux c'est
faux totalement faux c'est qu'ils me
pardonnent attention je connais des
artistes sont des musiciens
extraordinaires du nord il s'appelle ils
s'appellent les mauvaises langues
il chante devant 3000 personnes ils sont
jamais passés à la télé 1 il ya un
public en france extraordinaire il
manquera du linge aux fenêtres tant
qu'on pourra chanter c'est votre cas
jamais la star academy mission ma vie de
la star academy pourquoi pas à la limite
je ne pense que les mômes ont le droit
de rêver
par contre le droit de revendiquer les
mots pas de rêver d'accrocher de
revendiquer c'est de changer de quoi
dans l'est s'est dit lui même coiffure
qu hervé vilard aujourd'hui ce sera en
mer dans non ce qu'ici alors est ce
qu'il dit aujourd'hui lui dis que
finalement il ya le show business est
liée à la télé qui est lié à une
compagnie de téléphone mais est
finalement tout ça show business a
chanté le show business n'a jamais été
dans la chanson thierry le show business
il est ailleurs il est pas dans la
chanson mais la différence est que la
différence c'est que les gens vraiment y
pense que ils ont droit d'être célèbres
sont pas bosser c'est ça c'est ça et je
pense que c'est ça que la france
recherchent une star et star académie
c'est ça c'est l'idée qui met en mai
tête des jeunes
alors ça crée un malaise social qui est
la jalousie de la célébrité et
à l'âge de 21 ans là les jeunes filles
se rencontrent qui m'ont pas se marier
avec le capitaine de l'équipe de
football d'angleterre david beckham par
exemple et puis tombe dans la dépression
c'est c'est un malaise tual je pense et
les gens oublient qu est la musique
n'est pas à une compétition de
popularité c'est moi je pense si c'est
la violence parce que j'ai eu peur un
moment que ça se passe
les gens j'en pense que vraiment que le
rock'n'roll par exemple c'est que le
sexe drogue et rock'n a bien sûr que ça
existe dans ce monde là mais c'est de la
bosse on passe 18 - en tournée en ce cas
c'est 'qui pour vendre des disques de
mourir il a existé avant toi bien sûr et
toi tu as donné avant moi aussi il t'a
donné de la musique et à donner la
musique et écoute l'horrible moi je ça
peut paraître étonnant mais j'ai mûri
depuis très longtemps et est pas né
quand je crois pas arriver à vous
rencontrer son petit succès sur la toile
si ça va j'écouterai sont dix ouais
ouais mais je viens après partager à
50/50
alors voyez vous êtes devenu célèbre en
transformant votre angoisses
d'adolescent le teenage angst en art et
on va voir comment ça s'est passé
on va faire une interview trash
[Musique]
monaco à partir de quel âge avez vous
commencé à vous maquiller un vers l'âge
de 11 ans a les bains je faisais du
théâtre à l'école alors j'ai toujours
associé la scène avec le maquillage je
vous ai déjà porté string en cuir
inscrits en cuir non jamais oui bah
ouais tu dénonces lancé ce cri bordeaux
a oui quand il est 10h pour nous voyage
est ce que vous avez déjà vu du sang
jamais j'ai une copine
j'avais une copine il ya 5 6 ans qui a
vu m'ont semblé j'ai jamais vu tant de
quelqu'un d'autre mais pas des données
en un an
est ce que tu as déjà porter des
menottes ailleurs que dans un
commissariat
oui bien dans un tribunal et toi est-ce
que tu étais déjà filmé en train de
faire l'amour
jamais non j'ai pas envie que ça se
retrouve sur internet
est ce que tu as déjà sucer des talons
aiguilles non jeu léché des bottes mais
si c'est des talons aiguilles
est ce que tu as déjà partagé une copine
avec des potes ou l'inversé du pis en
sachant non est ce que tu as déjà porté
des vêtements de ta mère oui je soutiens
gorges a été sûr j'ai été sur est ce que
tu sais déjà automutilée ouais au
territoire et tous ici j'aimerais bien
et mon ami roi et la capacité de me de
faire de l'auto fellation et puis je
les sages de la des animaux pattes c'est
pas bon pour les lombaires il faudrait
qu est ce que tu t'es déjà automutilée
ben oui oui je les fais ouais
ben j'ai beaucoup souffert ben
exclusivement d'être super sérieux pour
l'instant mais je je je suis dépressif
chez beaucoup souffert de ça j'ai pris
pour longtemps des médicaments pour et
ouais il y avait des temps très noir
dans ma vie où je me suis auto mutilée
automutilée
je me retrouvais dans des chambres des
chambres d'hôtel et jusqu'à six dessins
et je fais mes champs mais heureusement
ça va mieux ces jours ci merci ça bien
c'est important d'en parler parce que je
peux ainsi ses formes très important que
parce que les jeunes sachent que des
gens comme moi ont passé par des choses
dans laquelle ils passent aussi parce
que moi je souffre d'une maladie qu'est
la dépression
et puis
c'est ça veut pas dire que c'est pas
possible de faire quelque chose de
positif même s'il ya quelque chose qui
dans sa tête ou qui quitta rétaux qui te
force à travailler en eau de te battais
mai et j'espère que je suis une
inspiration pour les gens elle c'est
pour ça que j'en parle je trouve que
c'est super important
est-ce que royal est ce que tu t'es déjà
raser les poils du torse
ouais tiens d'azur mais souvent way pour
des séances de photos ouais c'est a dû
le faire passer le temps son meilleur
jeu des coûts et de poils mais pourquoi
pour le strip ce n'est pas très
esthétique streetball qui reçoit nice et
rennes jours qu'il était c'est bizarre
c'est bon comme toujours qu'il est maçon
et vendeurs est ce que tu as déjà
regardé jean pierre pernaut à 13 heures
[Musique]
voilà un placebo
le co sleeping with ghosts réédition de
l'album mesdames messieurs le single
s'appelle protège moi avec des paroles
de virginie despentes et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de dinars 10 tubes
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu